évoquant la phalange de jeunes pilotes
qui avait défendu et sauver leur pays
face à l'aviation la plus puissante du
monde
la luftwaffe wiston churchill dira
jamais un aussi grand nombre d'hommes
n'a contracté une telle dette envers un
si petit
durant trois mois de juillet à septembre
1940 la royal air force et la luftwaffe
s'étaient affrontés dans un combat sans
merci qui constitue avec l'attak de
l'urss en juin 1941 le tournant majeur
de la seconde guerre mondiale
à
mais pour comprendre il faut remonter à
quelques semaines en arrière
10 mai 1940 la wehrmacht en veille les
pays bas le luxembourg la belgique et la
france
suivant le plan jaune conçu par l'occ
avait aubert commando der wehrmacht les
divisions blindées de panzers les
divisions d'infanterie fonce en avant
précédés soutenu par les parachutistes
du général shouldn't et les vagues de
chasseurs et de bombardiers de la
luftwaffe
si hitler a dû pour lancer son attaque
attendre que la météo se montre
favorable
le beau temps ce jour-là et son allié
oh
les pays bas sont la première victime de
l'assaut entraînés par leur victoire
facile de tchécoslovaquie de pologne
les soldats de la wehrmacht font preuve
d'une redoutable efficacité
la prise du fort des bennes hamel le
bombardement de rotterdam
la prise du canal albert sont pour eux
autant de nouvelles étapes victorieuse
dans le grondement des chars
roulements de l'artillerie
en cinq jours les pays bas sont à genoux
leur souveraine en fuite
rotterdam est en ruine malgré quelques
actions de résistance comme celle de la
cavalerie à hannut et à gembloux l'armée
française recule
le 24e mais les panzers arrive devant
dunkerque survolé par les vagues de
chtouka dans la ville et sur les plages
des centaines de milliers d'hommes
espère pouvoir être évacués des français
des belges mais surtout la majeure
partie du corps expéditionnaire anglais
commandé par l'ordre gort alors que la
bataille fait rage
hitler à l'étonnement de ses généraux
donne aux blindés l'ordre de stopper
alors qu'ils ne sont plus qu'à 30 km de
la mer cette décision inespéré va donner
aux britanniques le temps de lancer
l'opération dynamo et d'évacuer plus de
trois cent trente mille hommes 7 au
reich marshall hermann goering chef
suprême de la luftwaffe que les alliés
doivent ce répit ivre d'orgueil l'ancien
chef de l'escadrille reichshoffen a
obtenu du support l'autorisation
d'anéantir avec ses seuls avions les
britanniques et les français regroupés
sur les plages de dunkerque chasseurs et
bombardiers planche déjà sur le port et
la ville en feu je ne laisserai pas
pierre sur pierre ses ventes et
l'imposant maréchal devant les généraux
regroupés autour de lui mais ses pilotes
pourtant chevronné par l'expérience
acquise en pologne et bien souvent en
espagne sont fatigués par les combats
incessants des dernières semaines de
l'aveu même d'un nas comme adolf galande
la luftwaffe a subi de sérieuses pertes
depuis le début de la tacc pertes
infligées aussi bien par la ras
les aviateurs français ou l'adc à
plusieurs squadron d'interception
britannique sur les 51 que compte alors
la royal air force sont stationnés en
france s'y ajoutent plusieurs squadron
de bombardier entre le 26 mai le 5 juin
ils vont participer avec les squadron
basée en angleterre à la protection de
dynamos
derrière ces chasseurs hurricaines
expeed faire il y a la volonté d'un
homme le chef du fighter commandes l'air
chief marshal serious dining anciens de
l'armée des indes pilote en 1914
remarquable ce choeur célibataire et
écossais dao ding est alors âgé de 58
ans réaliste peut aimer daoud dean va
être à la fois l'âme de ses équipages et
le rigoureux représentants de la chasse
auprès du gouvernement tout comme
churchill il sait que l'angleterre va se
retrouver bientôt isolé face au
troisième reich et qu'elle va devoir se
défendre avec toutes ses forces
encore bien faible il se montre
farouchement opposée à l'envoi de
nouveaux squadron en france pour
répondre à la demande des aides que le
gouvernement de paul reynaud a formulé
son objectif conserver le maximum
d'avions pour s'opposer à l'aso
inéluctable de la luftwaffe
il convainc churchill mais doit
cependant accepté d'envoyer ses squadron
protéger leur et embarquement de
dunkerque
durant celui-ci les chasseurs de la ras
effectué 2739 sortie 106 avions sont
abattus et cinq pilotes sont tués ou
faits prisonniers
l'épaisse couche de nuages de fumée
cache le plus souvent le matériel laissé
sur place
plus important que le matériel il y a
les hommes britanniques français et
leurs alliés qui représente aussi et
surtout de futurs combattants y compris
pour la ras
dans les rangs de laquelle figureront
des pilotes de plusieurs nationalités
dont les futurs français libres mais
aussi des tchèques des polonais grâce à
la protection des chasseurs à l'action
des bombardiers ces dizaines de milliers
de rescapés tirés de l' os embarqué sur
une noria de bateaux de toutes tailles
et de tous genres vont pouvoir gagner ou
regagner l'angleterre
où
14 juin 1940 les troupes allemands
entrent dans paris et défilent sur la
place de l'étoile
quelques jours plus tard hitler lui même
fait une visite éclair dans cette
capitale qui l'a toujours fait rêver
la bataille de france est terminée
la bataille d'angleterre comme le
déclare judge il va pouvoir commencer
déjà les avions allemands attaquent les
navires britanniques croisant dans la
manche pour le monde qu'il observe
l'angleterre seul désormais face à
hitler ne pourra pas tenir plus de trois
semaines
ulcéré de voir ces offres de perfuser
par churchill hitler se prépare à
envahir l'angleterre
il compte pour cela sur la luftwaffe
dont ils visitent les escadrilles mais
il réunit surtout quarante et une
division dont six blindés
au total 260 mille hommes chargés de
mener à bien l'opération lions de mer ou
otaries qui se met en place sur les
côtes françaises
à grand renfort d'un impressionnant
matériel
la réussite de l'opération repose
essentiellement sur la maîtrise de l'air
par la luftwaffe
celles ci incluent l anéantissement du
fighter commande par les trois flottes
aériennes basées en belgique en hollande
en france et en scandinavie
mais à partir du 10 juillet date de
l'envoi de la première formation
importante de bombardier sur la grande
bretagne
les appareils de la luftwaffe se
contentent durant près d'un mois
d'attaqué les navires anglais de
survoler les ports et de mouiller des
mines dans la seconde semaine d'août
goering installé dans son train qg
décident d'agir plus énergiquement
il se fait fort de libérer le ciel de
l'aviation britannique en quatre jours
pour cela des milliers d'ouvriers du
service du travail et de l'organisation
top construisent de nouvelles bases à
proximité du champ de bataille
de l'autre côté de la manche le peuple
britannique attend et se prépare il a pu
constater les effets de la guerre éclair
menée sur le continent par la wehrmacht
chaque anglais c'est que son pays peut
subir le même sort alors tout le monde
se prépare hommes et femmes contribuant
à transformer l'île en forteresse
signe tangible de l'état de guerre les
enfants de londres et des principales
villes du sud de l'angleterre sont
évacués vers la campagne un certain
nombre même et diriger vers l'étranger
notamment vers les états unis
les civils subissent eux aussi un
entraînement militaire
ils vont jouer un rôle important dans la
surveillance des points sensibles et
l'observation du ciel dans lequel ne
vont pas tarder à apparaître les vagues
d'assaut allemande
la holding de son côté met en ligne
quatre groupements de chasse les 10e 11e
12e et 13e groupes composés chacun de 13
à 15 squadron comportant seize appareils
dont 12 immédiatement opérationnels et
quatre en réserve
cette structure s'appuie sur un réseau
radar composé de deux dispositifs de
détection équipe l1 de hautes tours
métalliques l'autre de relais le long
des côtes
en 1940 l'angleterre est le seul pays à
disposer d'un tel système
à cela s'ajoute un dispositif serré de
décès à et de guetteurs volontaire
la stratégie de darling symbolisée par
la célèbre opération home du quartier
général de stan mort installé à bentley
priori dans le sud de londres consiste à
exploiter les informations téléphoner
par les observateurs et les opérateurs
radars qui signalent immédiatement les
positions des avions allemands repérer
jusque dans un rayon de 200 km les
chasseurs reçoivent aussitôt l'ordre de
décoller et sont alors dirigés par radio
vers leurs adversaires les différentes
opérations brousse et leurs opérateurs
parmi lesquels les célèbres auxiliaires
féminine de la royal air force
contrôler les opérations des appareils
appartenant au groupe 11 dans le sud de
l'angleterre
spécialement chargé de l'interception
des chasseurs allemands au groupe 12
situé plus au nord et au groupe disso
sud-ouest chargé e de la protection des
bases de la ras
où
dès les premiers engagements il paraît
évident que la bataille qui commence va
être celle des chasseurs bien au delà
même des bombardiers plus exactement la
bataille d'angleterre va opposer trois
appareils
le messerschmitt 109 d'une part le
spitfire et leurs week-ends de l'autre
ayant fait ses preuves dès la guerre
d'espagne le messerschmitt 109 va durant
ces mois de combats intenses être
quotidiennement aux prises avec les deux
avions les plus célèbres de la royal air
force
il symbolise tous les trois le mythe qui
caractérise encore aujourd'hui la
bataille d'angleterre
mise au point par le célèbre avionneurs
willy messerschmidt le bf 109 comme on
l'appelle couramment et mise en service
en février 1937 issus du bf 108
il connaîtra plusieurs versions c'est le
bf 109 e
emile qui sera l'unique chasseurs
allemands de la bataille d'angleterre
équipé d'un moteur daimler benz e 601 ce
petit monoplace était rapide maniable
bien armé de deux mitrailleuses mg 17 de
7 mm 9 dans le nez et de deux canons de
20 mm dans les ailes il surclasse
plusieurs de ses adversaires
son seul véritable rival et le
légendaire spitfire supermarine fierté
justifier du fighter commandes
il est l'oeuvre de l'ingénieur hergies
mitchell qui le destine en 1930 et le
modifier en 1936 date de la première
mise en production
équipé d'un moteur merlin deux ou trois
le célèbre spitz reçoit un armement
keira de 4 à 8 mitrailleuse suivant les
séries auxquelles s'ajoutent pour les
spitz
ib deux canons de 20 mm sa capacité à
virey plus vite que le messerschmidt
donnera souvent au speed faire un
avantage décisif dans les combats de
chiens les dogfights qui caractérise les
duels entre chasseurs
les deux appareils sont fort proches
l'un de l'autre les trois bf 109 tomber
entre les mains des français des anglais
à l'automne et en hiver 1939 permettront
aux ingénieurs britanniques de constater
leur similitude plus que leurs
différences
le bf 109 grimpe ainsi plus rapidement
que le spitfire mais au dessus de 10000
pièces ce dernier présente une plus
grande maniabilité de la même façon le
messerschmitt 109 pic plus vite en
raison de son moteur à injection
alors que le speed frères perd de la
puissance des kills inclinée vers le bas
le carburateur coupant le moteur sous
l'effet de la gravité
globalement cependant le spitfire est
supérieur à son adversaire
sa maniabilité lui donnant un net
avantage dans les affrontements qui pour
la plupart se déroulent à une altitude
variant entre 13000 et 20 mille pieds
ces deux chasseurs sur place par leurs
performances
le chasseur bombardier juncker 88 plus
connu sous le nom de chtouka qui lourd
lent et peu maniable sera surtout
redouté pour ses fantastiques piqué
accompagné d'un hurlements de sirènes
stridents qui terrorise les marins des
navires visé mais la différence
essentielle entre le bf 109 et le spicg
ra air sera faite par la faible
autonomie du premier qui venant du
continent pour combattre au dessus de la
manche ou de l'angleterre ne dispose pas
de plus de 15 minutes de carburant
pendant l'affrontement
paradoxalement malgré leurs qualités
respectives ces deux chasseurs les sont
un troisième type d'appareil le rocker
éric n l'honneur d'être le plus grand
tueur de la bataille d'angleterre
ces huit mitrailleuse d'elle et son
moteur rolls royce merlin 2 lui
permettant d'accomplir des performances
remarquables notamment à l'encontre des
bombardiers allemands conçu en 1934 par
ciné calmes
l'américaine sera la véritable cheville
ouvrière du fighter commandes et
équipera de nombreuses squadron dont
celui du groupe captain townsend les
pilotes des deux camps en fait le même
état d'esprit
les britanniques john baird en sont pour
beaucoup issus de la volontaire reserve
composé d'étudiants pour qu'ils volaient
est avant tout un sport grisant ils
cultivent leur apparence affectant une
certaine décontraction et des fantaisies
vestimentaires inséparable d'un courage
à toute épreuve les pilotes allemands
aussi jeunes bénéficiaient cependant
bien souvent de l'expérience acquise en
pologne et pour les plus anciens en
espagne
cette expérience les britanniques la
subiront souvent et ne manqueront pas de
la signaler à chaque retour de vol
il ne faut pas non plus oublier de
chaque côté les mécaniciens qui assurait
l'un g est indispensable entretien des
appareils soumis à la rude épreuve du
combat usant les machines comme les
aubes sur ce plan une autre différence
et par les adversaires
tout pilote anglais a battu peut a
priori reprendre le combat
alors qu'un pilote allemand tombé à
l'eau près des côtes britanniques est
immanquablement faits prisonniers
au début du mois de juillet 1940 donc
les appareils allemands commencent à
attaquer les bateaux britanniques et à
larguer des mines dans la manche mais
bombardier lance quelques raids de nuit
à l'intérieur du pays quant aux
chasseurs y compris les dix moteurs bf
110 il tente de contraindre leurs
adversaires à combattre
la holding ne tombe pas dans le piège de
limites série il entend garder ces
quelques 900 chasseurs opérationnels
disponibles pour la grande attaque qui
il en est sûr se déclenchera bientôt
il clair en fait commis une lourde
erreur en attaquant pas en force
les navires britanniques transportant
les rescapés de dunkerque ses
adversaires mettent ce délai à profit
pour affiner leurs réseaux radar leur
système de gays et de décès a pour
entraîner leurs pilotes et accéléré leur
production d'avions
déjà les pertes sont sensibles dans
chaque camp dès la seconde semaine
d'août les anglais ont perdu 148
appareils et la luftwaffe 286 dont 105
bf 109
du sol les guetteurs britanniques
peuvent observer les pilotes de la rs
leur tactique se ressent leur manque
d'expérience volant en formation serrée
ils forment une cible facile pour la
flac comme pour les chasseurs allemands
qui savent manoeuvrer pour arrivé par
derrière dans la queue de leurs
adversaires et les abattre en pilote au
54e squadron disaient ils sortent du
soleil vous tombe dessus comme l'éclair
la salle manga landes écrit de son côté
la première règle du combat aérien et
d'être le premier à repérer l'adversaire
attentif à rester en formation elle
contre elle les pilotes britanniques
peuvent à peine repérer leurs
adversaires et lorsque ceux-ci
surgissent il manque de l'espace
nécessaire pour manoeuvrer
c'est pourquoi les pertes de la ra f
sont dès le début très élevé six pilotes
dans la seule journée du 20 juillet
rapidement d'ailleurs les mécaniciens de
la ras invente une parade en plaçant un
blindage derrière le siège des pilotes
ce qui sauvera la vie de beaucoup
d'entre eux et leur permettra de
regagner leurs bases sains et saufs
comme celui que l'on voit ici accueilli
par ses camarades et l'officier de
renseignement et qu'il raconte son
combat
tirant la leçon qui s'imposaient des
premiers vide enregistrés dans les
squadron d'autant plus inquiétant que le
manque de pilotes risquaient de se faire
sentir très vite le commandement de la
ras modifier très vite tactique et
entraînement
paradoxalement la manière de voler
s'inspire des méthodes de la luftwaffe
et principalement de la formation quatre
doigts
mise au point par le major werner mulder
ce prestigieux commandant de l'aiac
gâche vadder 51 dans cette formation un
avion est placé à chaque extrémité de
chacun des doigts écartés d'une main
imaginaire
ces problèmes de tactiques sont alors
dans cette phase préliminaire de la
bataille source de conflit entre darling
et les ervices marshall parc et lima
laurie les deux premiers veulent
conserver des formations souple et
facilement employeur pour la riposte
alors que le troisième est partisan de
formation supérieure en nombre à celle
des allemands appelés grandes ailes
il en résulte des dissensions d'état
major qui ont des échos jusque dans les
escadrilles la sangle est douglas pas
d'heure notamment est un farouche
partisan de la théorie des grandes ailes
et voudrais la mettre en application
malgré l'opposition de down ding et de
parcs qui estime que l'arrivée d'une
importante formation et demi est connu
trop tard pour permettre le
rassemblement d'une force de riposte
suffisante il faut en effet 17 minutes
un squadron pour arriver sur le lieu du
combat et 20 autres minutes pour se
mettre en formation de grandes ailes
avec d'autres squadron ces délais
beaucoup trop long donne raison à downs
il n'y a pas
les combats proprement dit ne dure pas
plus de 10 à 15 minutes et sont
fréquemment visible de chaque côté de la
manche dans chaque camp les pilotes
restent en alerte plus de 12 heures par
jour
certaines formations britanniques à ce
stade de la bataille effectué jusqu'à
quatre sorties par jour
volant à chaque fois environ 1h30
du côté des allemands le rythme est
moins soutenu pour le moment mais trois
sorties quotidiennes pour les chasseurs
ou les choucas n'ont rien d'exceptionnel
si dans l'ensemble cet été 1940 est beau
et doux des bourrasques voire des orages
balle et parfois la mer ajoutons brume
du matin et du soir et au vent froid qui
pousse de temps à autres d'importants
nuages
ces conditions atmosphériques joue un
rôle dans la récupération des pilotes
britanniques ou allemands tombés à la
mer
cette récupération est d'autant plus
essentiel que les pilotes sont plus
rares que les appareils autant que la
morale l'intérêt commun des deux
commandements de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour les repêcher
les britanniques utilisent des vedettes
à moteur qui reçoivent souvent l'aide de
petits bâtiments de commerce ou de pêche
les allemands eux emplois plutôt des
hydravions blanc marqué de la croix
rouge mais après qu un spitfire est
abattu un hydravion en plein combat
le ministère de l'air britannique donne
officiellement l'ordre d'abattre tout
avion ambulance avec ou sans
identification de la croix rouge
s'il s'aventurait dans la zone de
combats il s'agit tout autant d'empêcher
les allemands de récupérer trop de
pilotes de la luftwaffe que de capturer
ce de la ras
bien plus que les avions les véritables
héros de la bataille d'angleterre sont
les pilotes
quel que soit leur camp c'est durant
cette bataille que la notion das va
prendre toute son importance elle ne
fera que se développer par la suite
allemand anglais français
les as autant commun la jeunesse le
courage la témérité même et un amour du
vol qui les pousse à monter dans le ciel
est assis battre généralement sans haine
pour leurs adversaires
seule exception les polonais les
tchèques engagées dans la r f qui ont
des motifs personnels de détester les
pilotes de la luftwaffe de chaque côté
des pilotes prestigieux devienne la
coqueluche des donations werner mulder
ce que l'on voit ici rentré de mission
adolphe galande hellmuth vic gunther
loads au hand philippe sont quelques-uns
des ans allemands douglas bader stanford
tuck johnny johnston allant dire peter
en scène riche à hillary honore la rff
par leurs exploits
tout comme clostermann ou henry
bouquillard les forces aériennes
françaises libres
l'obr le tenante max hellmuth ostermann
qui obtiendra cette victoire pendant la
bataille et terminera la guerre avec un
palmarès de 100 avions abattus et la
croix de chevalier avec feuilles de
chêne et épais décrite ainsi l'un de ses
combats au dessus de la manche par
rapport à mes combats en france j'étais
très calme
je n'essayais pas systématiquement de
tirer mais avant tout de trouver la
meilleure position
le tome i se dérober à chaque fois
jusqu'au moment où la chance me sourit
juste au dessous moi je vis un bf 109
poursuivi à deux cents mètres par un
spitfire je virais et 20 me mettre
derrière lui
maintenant c'est moi qui me trouvaient à
200 mètres dans c'est que je rester
calme ne pas faire feu immédiatement
j'augmentais progressivement ma vitesse
elle est appliquée réduire la distance
tout comme le tome i le faisait avec sa
propre cible
soudain il tira et le messerschmidt
dégageait au même instant je pressais le
bouton de les armes visant calmement
l'auto me vire à gauche mais mes
premiers tirs n'avaient touché un long
panache de fumée grise se dégageait
derrière lui il tomba dans la mer tout
près de la côte
une colonne liquide marca le crash je
peux annoncer ma victoire par radio et
des témoins pour la confirmer je venais
de descendre mon premier anglais
les pilotes britanniques commencent à
subir un rythme d'enfer les allemands
attaquent de plus en plus fréquemment
leurs adversaires sont épuisés par les
alertes répétées qui les jettent dans
leurs appareils et les font décoller en
quelques minutes les pertes
s'accroissent
pourtant la production de guerre
progresse au cours du seul mois de
juillet les usines d'armement dirigée
par lord beaverbrook ministre de la
production aéronautique réussissent à
construire 496 chasseur soit quatre fois
plus que la production mensuelle
habituelle avant d'un cas les
rodomontades de göring n'avait pas été
confirmée non seulement la rhf n'est pas
détruite mais encore la luftwaffe a subi
de lourdes pertes
nous étions encore loin d'avoir conquis
la maîtrise de l'air écrit adolphe
galande dans son célèbre ouvrage
jusqu'au bout surnommé sert schmitt il
écrit encore les unités de chasse
allemande de la manche exécutèrent
démission qui se succèdent et
constamment
il était normal d'en faire deux ou trois
par jour chasse libre sur le sud est de
l'angleterre
tels étaient en général leur énoncé les
forts physiques et psychiques subis par
les pilotes étaient considérables le
personnel au sol et les avions eux aussi
étaient soumis à des efforts extrêmes
nous nous étions chaque jour contre la
défense britannique et nous la perdions
avec des pertes considérables mais sans
nous rapprocher sensiblement de
l'objectif qui nous avaient été assignés
nous nous en prenions à nos dirigeants
bombardier ou chtouka au destroyer à
nous mêmes nous voyons disparaître de
nos rangs un camarade après l'autre des
compagnons d'armes ancien est sûre il ne
se passe pas de jour sans qu'une place
reste à vide lors des repas pris en
commun de nouveau visage apparaissait
nous devenus familiers et un jour il ne
reparaît s'est pas abattue en combat
aérien au dessus de l'angleterre
durant ces jours là dans tous les hauts
parleurs du grand reich allemand d'aix
la chapelle a t'il site et de flensburg
à innsbruck et même par l'intermédiaire
des émetteurs militaires installés dans
les pays occupés de presque toute
l'europe
on entendait le champ bonbonnes à of
england des bombes sur l'angleterre
nous nous en avons eu immédiatement
jusque là de ce champ
non
oh
j'aimerais
pendant ce temps les hommes politiques
et la propagande allemande s'attendait à
la montée en puissance de la bataille
par sa directive numéro 17
hitler décide de créer des conditions
nécessaires à la conquête finale de
l'angleterre dès le 5 août les services
de renseignement britanniques sont au
courant et le 8
ding ding s'adresse aux membres du
fighter commande la bataille
d'angleterre va commencer membre de la
royal air force le sort de génération
est entre vos mains sur toutes les bases
allemand des pilotes consulter les
cartes et reçoivent les ordres
les équipages vérifie chaque détail les
appareils chasseurs messerschmidt 109 et
110 ch tout cas bombardier heinkel 111
dornier yonker 88 se prépare à décoller
ce même 8 août les combats font rage
plus de mille sortie de part et d'autre
31 avions allemands et 19 anglais sont
abattus mais ce n'est rien en prévision
de l'assaut final dont le nom de code
est le tag le jour de l'aigle sa date
est fixée au 13 août dès le 12 les
bombardiers de la luftwaffe pilonnent
les ports anglais les aérodromes de la
côte et les stations radar afin de
désorganiser les défense britannique
malgré les coups au but d'ouvrir à yapen
c'est notamment le système radar n'est
pas trop gravement touchés et les
opérations nous sommes des différents
secteurs bien que perturbée par ces
attaques en masse continue à diriger les
escadrilles de la ravir les agresseurs
plus de 100 juncker 88,2 comme ken
schrader 51 accompagné de 120 mais
cherche mixant 10 et de 25 bf 109
attaque le sud de l'angleterre
soixante dix longueurs 88 bombes à
portsmouth le port les docks la vieille
ville et l'île de wight
ils détruisent la station radar de 29
dont le rôle de protection est
primordial hantson les derniers du quang
et schnyder 2 anéanti sous leurs bombes
la base du 65e squadron de speed frère
à la fin de la journée les britanniques
ont perdu 22 chasseurs et les allemands
31 dans le camp anglais les dommages ne
sont pas définitifs quatre des cinq
stations radars sont remises en état en
quelques heures et la base de bombardier
de his church pilonné à la suite d'une
erreur des allemands qui la prenait pour
une base de chasseurs est à nouveau
rapidement opérationnels à berchtesgaden
hitler est tenu au courant heure par
heure
l'aube du jour de l'aigle se lève sur
les nuages et la pluie que rinne décide
de reporter la taca l'après midi mais
son ordre ne parvient pas à temps à
l'armada de bombardier est alors escorte
de chasseurs qui a décollé dans un
tonnerre assourdissant vers l'angleterre
seuls quelques formations de
messerschmidt 110 rebroussent chemin
ajoutant à la confusion qui s'empare de
la luftwaffe les bombardiers se retrouve
sans escorte de nombreux combats
opposent tout cas et speed frères
notamment ceux du 609e groupe de la rff
qui sous le commandement du squadron
leader d'arles et abattent neuf
adversaires 150 bombardier juncker 88 et
chtouka escorté de bf 109 attaque
southampton
malgré la riposte des chasseurs de la r
f ils réussissent à incendier une bonne
partie des bassins et des entrepôts
d'autres formations allemandes ces gars
ou se trompe d'objectif
au cours de cette journée historique la
luftwaffe enregiste 1485 sortie contre
700 pour la r f
les résultats ne sont pas cependant
aussi brillant que ne le croient vieux
ring dont les services de renseignement
sont trop optimiste en annonçant la
destruction de 70 chasseurs et 18
bombardier les anglais n'ont en effet
perdu que 13 chasseurs la luftwaffe par
contre déplore la perte effectif de onze
chasseurs et de 23 bombardiers
très vite cependant le commandement de
la luftwaffe se rend compte que le
système radar des britanniques est
intacte pour goering sa destruction
définitive devient prioritaire
pour daoud dean ce résultat tient du
miracle et il le dit nettement tout en
reconnaissant la valeur et le courage de
ses pilotes du courage ils vont en avoir
besoin très vite
deux jours plus tard le 15 août ils vont
devoir affronter la plus importante
opération aérienne depuis le début de la
guerre
ce jour là le général stumpf commandant
de la 5e flotte aérienne basée en
norvège et au danemark reçoit l'ordre de
jeter dans la bataille ses hydravion en
quel sens 15 et 72 bombardier en quel
sens son objectif lancer une attaque
surprise à travers la mer du nord contre
les aérodromes et les centres
industriels du nord-est de l'angleterre
dans la région de newcastle mais stumpf
ignore que les anglais connaissent ces
codes repérer par radar une heure avant
leur arrivée les bombardiers et leur
escorte de chasseurs sont dispersés
notamment par les appareils du 13e group
commandée par l'air vis marshall saül
les attaques se succèdent toute la
journée dans le sud notamment contre l'
usine de rochester à l'est de londres
les bombardiers allemands se trompent
plusieurs fois de cible et pilonnent des
aérodromes de moindre importance comme
croydon et ouest meiling au lieu
d'atteindre begin île où qu'elle l'ait
les escadrilles britannique réagissent
très vite et se précipite à la rencontre
de leurs adversaires en fin de journée
la rs n'a pas perdu un seul appareil
alors que la luftwaffe lot 5 rentrer
péniblement en norvège
ayant essuyé 20 % de pertes seule la
base de bombardier de dry field dans le
yorkshire a été détruite
les chasseurs de l'air vis marshall
ligue mallory n'ayant pas réussi à
intercepter les juncker 88 le 15 août
représente une victoire certaine pour la
rfc pilotes ont effectué 974 sortie
contre 1780 pour la luftwaffe dont 520
raid de bombardiers
on ne reverra pas de tels chiffres avant
longtemps une fois éliminées les
exagérations de part et d'autre
les comptes font apparaître 34 victoires
pour les allemands et 75 pour les
anglais malgré cela la situation est
préoccupante pour ces derniers hangar
incendié piste criblé de cratères de
bombes non seulement sur les côtes mais
à l'intérieur du pays par contre le
fighter commande n'a pas vraiment
souffert de cette attaque les avions
abattus étant des monoplaces alors que
les appareils allemands comprenez
généralement trois ou quatre hommes
d'équipage
les combats se poursuivent sans
discontinuer jusqu'au 18 août en quatre
jours la rfa bas 194 avions allemands
sur près de 300 kilomètres longeant la
côte sud de l'angleterre
il n'y a pas un coin de ciel calme à
karine al goering se rend compte que ce
bilan est inacceptable il doit prendre
un certain nombre de décisions
stratégiques
furieux le reich marshall rend la chasse
responsable de l'échec ce qui lui aliène
naturellement les pilotes de chasse
galles inde en tête
il retire de la bataille et chtouka
l'esbf 110 qui ont été particulièrement
éprouvés mais surtout il ordonne aux
chasseurs une protection renforcée des
bombardiers il ordonne aussi aux
commandants des flottes aériennes de
concentrer leur action sur les bases les
usines les installations de toutes
sortes et de nantes où la préférence aux
bombardiers goering comme elle à une
erreur stratégique dont il va se
repentir nordine profite du répit de
quelques jours entre le 18 et le 24 août
marqué par le mauvais temps et en
profite pour compenser ces pertes en
hommes et en appareils
il en a besoin car près de 150 de ses
pilotes ont été tués ou blessés et 213
hurricane et spitfires ont été détruits
en dix jours à ce rythme là r af court
le risque d'être anéantie à ces
questions tactiques s'ajoutent les
dissensions de plus en plus profonde
entre les ervices marshall park hee lee
mallory collaborateurs immédiate down
ding et commandants respectifs des 11e
et 12e groupe
la nouvelle tactique du fighter
commandes consiste à laisser les
formations allemandes s'enfoncer à
l'intérieur du territoire afin de les
attaquer lorsqu'elles seront le plus
éloignés de leurs bases
ceci répond aux décisions du
commandement de la luftwaffe qui décide
d'envoyer des petites formations de
bombardier bien protégé par les
chasseurs qui en outre balaie le ciel en
chasse libre en avant du dispositif
visitant les escadres y stationner dans
le nord de la france dans la région du
pas de calais du catelier
goering ne ménage pas ses invectives
vis-à-vis de ses pilotes
profondément choquée par ces
remontrances mais celle ci suscite aussi
chez une sorte de rage qui renforce leur
combativité au moment même où
l'offensive à reprendre la seconde phase
de la bataille d'angleterre a pour les
allemands un objectif précis éliminer
totalement la puissance aérienne
britannique
dans l'esprit de goering le temps des
combats au dessus de la manche est
achevée
samedi 24 août par un temps radieux les
bombardiers allemands accompagnés de
leurs escortes de chasseurs attaqué base
du deuxième groupe situés dans le kent
manston orne church et north wales sont
sérieusement touché londres et sa
banlieue sont également bombardé la
période qui commence va être la plus
meurtrière pour les pilotes de la f1
jusqu'au 6 septembre
plus de 23 % des effectifs vont être
perdus
même s'il en a battu 530 appareils
allemands soit presque 40 par jour
la plupart des tués sont des pilotes
expérimentés pour les remplacer on fait
appel à 260 pile nouvellement formés ou
venant du beurre ou du coastal commandes
reconverti en toute hâte en pilote de
chasse
leur espérance de vie ne dépasse pas une
vingtaine d'heures de combat et beaucoup
vont mourir dès les premières minutes de
leur engagement
l'hémorragie est la même du côté des
allemands près de 15% des pilotes
disparaissent
la protection des aérodromes et de plus
en plus nécessaire park et ding ding
malgré tout persistent dans leur
opposition à la stratégie des 'grands'
elle prôné par lee mallory park finit
par exiger l'aide du commandant du
onzième groupe qui s'incline à
contrecoeur mais dont les avions ne
parviennent pas le 31 août empêcher le
bombardement de la plupart des bases sud
de l'angleterre dont les installations
et les hangars sont anéantis les câbles
sectionnés les avions détruits et le
personnel tu es l'aérodrome névralgique
de begin il est mis provisoirement hors
de combat
les pilotes de la rfa combattent dans
des conditions effrayantes de tension et
de fatigue
peter temps scène du 85e squadron écrit
dans ses mémoires sans perdre le sens de
l'humour partie de croydon et grimpe en
plein gaz je pouvais voir d'affreux
champignon de fumée noire s'épanouir en
direction du sud
j'avais cravacher sans pitié mans
éricaine durant la grimpée et je me
rapprochais très vite dm 110 l'escadron
me suivait il me suffisait de le savoir
je sais c'est d'y penser je n'avais plus
qu'une idée rejoindre cette bande de mal
élevé qui avait dérangé notre repas
écrasé notre terrain est envahi notre
ciel
les hommes sont épuisés ne prenant que
quelques instants de repos entre deux
alertes dans la seule journée du 30 août
le fighter commandes effectué plus de
1000 sortie le temps s'écoule est
inexorablement écrite un autre pilote
la tension monte jusqu'aux limites du
supportable spitfire et week-end
décollent et atterrissent sur un rythme
infernal
il faut 35 minutes pour faire le plein
de carburant et de munitions puis on
s'envole à nouveau avec pour seule
perspective tuer ou être tué
dans ces conditions il n'est pas
étonnant que la machine humaine et ses
défaillances
ainsi de blenheim sont descendus par des
hurricanes qui les prennent pour des
bombardiers allemands un pilote
désorienté criblent de balles un
paisible tracteur
au soir du 31 août le fighter commandes
compte 39 appareil abattu et 14 pilotes
tués ou disparus
c'est le plus lourd bilan registre et en
une seule journée par la rs6 déranger
d'appareils tout neuf s'aligne sur les
terrains en remplacement de ceux qui ont
été abattus les pilotes eux manquent de
plus en plus le commandement n'a même
plus le temps d'entraîner les jeunes
hommes qui arrivent dans les escadrilles
sans aucune pratique de vol
paradoxalement le fighter commande va
trouver un soutien de poids dans le bon
beurre comme dont les pilotes écrémé par
les transferts vers la chasse vont jouer
un rôle important dans les semaines à
venir et appuyer le changement de
stratégie
celle ci est dû à l'erreur commise par
deux avions allemands qui dans la nuit
du 24 au 25 août
rentrant d'un raid sur rochester largue
involontairement leurs bombes sur la
banlieue de londres
en représailles le bon beurre commandant
voix 80 appareils détruire l'usiné
simone alc à berlin ils ne trouvent pas
leurs objectifs et la chaleur baume sur
berne le cours de la bataille
d'angleterre va en être changée le 4
septembre furieux hitler ordonne le
bombardement systématique de londres
le 7 septembre dans l'après-midi goering
exultant regarde du cap gris-nez les
vagues de bombardier se dirigeait sur
londres plus de 400 appareils dernier
henckel escorté de chasseurs les anglais
vont être totalement surpris aucune
disposition n'est prise pour une attaque
en masse de cette importance
volant très haut les bombardiers sont
inaccessibles à l'adc a et à l'achat ce
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas là les
premières bombes explosent sur l'arsenal
de woolwich puis sur les quais les docks
dans lesquels sont stockés les
approvisionnements nécessaires à la
capitale victoria & albert dox west
indian nox et les commercial d'auckland
des navires cool les ponts et les
passerelles s'écroulent les grues
bascule le pétrole sans flammes dans la
nuit 318 bombardier relais la première
vague les civils réfugiés dans le métro
vont payer un lourd tribut 448 sont
tuées et plus d'un millier blessées
et ce n'est qu'un début la ville est un
immense brasier qui s'éclaire
d'elle-même et facilite le travail des
bombardiers allemands à partir du 9
septembre la chasse anglais se ressaisit
le onzième groupe de park contre attaque
et abat 28 appareils en en perdant quand
même 19 mai les chasseurs des scores de
la luftwaffe commencent à hésiter car
ils sont loin de leurs bases les
bombardements continuent cependant
surtout de nuit du 8 au 14 septembre
2011 aux miens sont tuées et plus de dix
mille blessés dans liste n ravagé les
pompiers et les sauveteurs découvrent à
chaque instant de nouveaux corps au
milieu des ruines
goering persuadé que le feuilleton
commandez maintenant exemple décide de
porter le coup final qu'il fixe au
dimanche 15 septembre ce jour là vers le
milieu de la matinée environ 400
bombardier 700 chasseurs se dirige dans
groupe compact vers la capitale mais
cette fois ci les anglais les attendent
11 squadron du onzième groupe ont déjà
pris l'air et montent vers les
assaillants
on
près de 22 escadre y soit 300 avions
vont engager le combat
las douglas bader censé protéger
certains abords du nord de londres ne
peut résister à la tentation de voler
vers le sud et d'attaquer lui aussi avec
ses 5 squadron très vite les pilotes de
chasse allemand comprenne qu'il n'est
plus temps de protéger les bombardiers
et fonce vers leurs adversaires qui se
faufilent entre les formations les
bombardiers de la première vague
repartent en ordre dispersé vers la
france remplacé par une seconde vague
escorté elle aussi de chasseurs les
combats se déroulent dans un ciel vierge
de tout nuage sous les yeux des
londoniens qui regardent ce spectacle
exceptionnel est mortelle la seconde
formation allemande n'a pas plus de
succès que la première
elle est notamment attaqué par bader et
huit autres squadron des 11e et 12e
groupe
les chasseurs allemands sont taboues
d'autonomie et les bombardiers
démoralisé larguer leurs bombes et
prennent la fuite
au crépuscule la ra effet l'angleterre
exulte un journal imprime 185 avions
descendu le résultat réel est plus
modeste la luftwaffe n'a perdu que 56
appareils au cours de ce qui restera
cependant pour elle le jour le plus noir
de toute la bataille
goering est effondré et furieux il
s'obstine pendant 24 heures a affirmé
que la ra effet à bout de souffle mais
ses généraux et les pilotes eux savent à
quoi s'en tenir
l'amirauté allemande voit l'automne
approché tout débarquement en angleterre
devient aléatoire
hitler lui aussi est convaincu il sait
que la luftwaffe a subi un grave échec
malgré les prouesses individuelles de
bon nombre de chasseurs le 17 septembre
il ordonne la journée l'opération lions
de mer
pendant trois mois encore la luftwaffe
poursuit ses bombardements sur londres
et le sud de l'angleterre causant de
nombreux dégâts
les anglais se précipitent encore dans
les caves le fighter commandant voit
encore ces chasseurs vers l'assaillant
de nombreux combats ont encore lieu au
dessus de la manche
mais la bataille d'angleterre est
réellement terminée
cette victoire difficile et douloureuse
a par contre affirmé l'esprit combatif
de la grande bretagne qui prend la tête
des nations belligérants opposée à
l'allemagne hitlérienne à laquelle elle
vient d'infliger sa première défaite les
pays occupés ou qui le seront plus tard
ne soupçonne pas encore le sort qui leur
est réservé mais la bataille
d'angleterre leur prouve que l'armée
allemande n'est pas invincible
même si celle ci va encore remporté de
nombreuses victoires
ben bouali mer jaune affiche comme
surprime chaillot
les tiger-cats braille
paradoxalement la fin de la bataille
d'angleterre entraîne une aggravation
des différends entre dining parc et
leurs détracteurs qui reproche notamment
au premier d'avoir mal conduit la
bataille et de ne l'avoir gagné que de
justesse la polémique s'enfle opposants
surtout dans dinelli malaurie elle fera
rage jusqu'à la fin de la guerre pour
dandine la conclusion sera rapide
le 16 novembre 1940 il devra sur un
simple coup de téléphone remettre son
commandement il sera remplacé par shaun
taux de glace parc sera relevé par lima
laurie le théoricien de la stratégie des
grandes elles seules consolations young
banding sera anobli en 1942 quelques
années après la guerre lasse néo
zélandais allant dire conclure à
dandiner parc ou gagner la bataille
d'angleterre mais ils ont perdu la
bataille des mots qui a suivi
le brigand pas aller à la radio
même temps
e
une
où